- So, y'all haven't met right?
- [David] No we just met. - [Octavia] No.
- That's what I love about this show.
I just love random people meeting each other.
- I heard you like to hug pillows.
- How did you hear that?
- They told me, if she reaches for your pillow
just let her have it.
(all laughing)
- Do you know why?
I know why you probably do that.
I have short legs, I'm short.
And I have to have a pillow back here so my feet
can touch the dang ground.
- Yes.
- That's what I'm doing now.
- My feet on The Voice chair are dangling.
My legs are like numb by the end of the show,
cause they don't reach the floor.
- Thank you.
- It's a problem.
- It is a problem.
- I'm good you guys can have all my pillows.
- Okay, bragger, "I'm so tall".
- Look at this.
- I'm so tall.
(audience laughs)
- Hey we were just talking actually in the break.
This is random but I didn't know that she was such like
a super heroes film guru.
I am too, like I love 'em.
Do you love them?
Like End Games?
Did you watch that?
- Superhero?
- Are you a superhero freak?
- Oh my God, I'm obsessed with it.
I'm the biggest superhero fan, like Robert Downey Jr
is my all time--
- My gosh, that's what started it, we were talking
about Dr. Doolittle, she's coming up in that
and I was like, "Oh I love Robert Downey" yeah
we were both talking but that's not called.
I can't talk, bok bok bok.
- No, you're good, I can't either.
I'll do that like seven times.
I'm like the biggest fan of him and I got to
host the Teen Choice Awards a couple months back.
- Whoa yeah.
- Yeah, I don't know how that happened either.
It's all very confusing.
- Okay let me tell you these things keep happening
because you're likable.
People like you.
- [Octavia] Yeah, yeah.
- Okay, no, no, no, you're getting paid for this.
(audience cheering)`
- So...
- You're doing good.
- I got to like where all the trailers where or whatever
to get ready for the show.
And my trailer was right across from Robert Downey Jr's.
And I seen him walking up and I--
Can I stand up?
- Yes.
- No.
- No, we don't stand on my show.
(all laughs)
- And he's coming down this way and I'm coming
out of the trailer and I go up to him and I go, "Hi".
- You hit puberty?
- And he goes, and he's so sweet, he goes, "who are you?
"Tell me everything".
And I go, "I have nothing to say to you, I am just the
biggest fan of you" and I just went, "I'll see you later"
and I went back into the trailer.
And I just got back in, I was like (inhales deeply)
(audience laughs)
Like just terrified and then later, like about 30--
- You met Iron Man.
- He's a sweetheart.
- Yeah, it was crazy.
- Oh my God.
- And he's so sweet.
- It's real.
- Oh really?
Good, don't you hate when they're not nice?
- Yeah, no he's exactly what--
- You're like, "Ugh".
- And he's Iron Man in real life too.
Like, it's not even a movie, he's actually Tony Stark.
And then--
- Okay, if he actually has some flying robots
we need to be friends.
- I need to talk to him.
- I think you're gonna do it in front of me.
Um, but then 30 minutes later then I'm coming out
to host the Teen Choice Awards and I see him sitting
like right on the side, like in the audience or whatever.
And I'm just like, "I cannot imagine what he is thinking"
like seeing me host the show when I couldn't even like
say a sentence to the guy.
- [Kelly] Talk. (laughs)
- He's probably like so, this guy really snuck into
the whole thing.
(all laughs)
So that was really cool.
That was like my favorite moment.
- That's amazing, I love meeting people you love
and they just like live up to everything.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- That's so cool.
- I didn't get to talk to him much cause I
freaked out but I'm sure he would if I had a conversation.
- I'm the same way, everything leaves, all of a sudden
I'm just an idiot.
The same thing happens to me, yeah.
- Me too.
- Really?
- Who have you met that you just completely--
- Who did you freak out?
- I like bear hugged Steven Spielberg.
- Oh my God.
- And I was sweating bricks and just like,
"I love you so much" and then I realize I was
squeezing him too tight.
(kelly laughs)(audience laughs)
Same thing with Oprah.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh.
- I mean, just, you know, you just can't control yourself
sometimes you know.
- I know.
- I wouldn't be able to control myself.
- And it's a huge compliment though cause if people
are that affected by you then you must be doing something
really awesome, you know.
- Until it's happening to you and you don't know
what's happening.
(all laughs)
- I love it.
- Let me go.
- I think it's so sweet cause I freak out over people
like that so I'm always like, "No, I totally get it".
Like, I freak out too.
- I freaked out.
- So for these of people who aren't familiar with Ick
what is your actual job?
Like, what do you do every day?
- Sure, okay.
- Cause I want it, cause you get like billions of views.
- Yeah so I make videos with my friends.
Basically, the best way to describe it to somebody
who doesn't know is it's just trying to have, trying
to find new ways to have fun with my friends every day.
I guess that's kinda like the cheesy way to say it.
- That's awesome.
- [Octavia] I love that.
- Yeah, and that's pretty much it.
So we just record our lives--
- The greatest job.
- It genuinely, like I'm not just saying this--
- Where do you live?
- Studio City, right up the hill.
- I'm gonna come and be in a video.
(audience applauds)
- We're just gonna show up.
- I'm just gonna show up.
- In End Games. - With Zelma.
- When Zelma dresses Iron Man.
And we're ready.
- No but yeah that's about it, we're just like
always, I don't know, I don't know, every day
is completely new.
- So what's your most memorable video that you've
ever been a part of?
- My most memorable?
Well, I did, the one I get the most when I see people
is, I have a friend and we were just joking around
and he tells me, he's like, "You'll never find love,
"you'll never find someone to marry you" like as a joke.
So then the next day I flew to Boston, without him knowing,
and I proposed to his mother--
(all laughing)
and then yeah--
- That's like the ultimate revenge.
- It was great, it was great.
So I proposed to his mom, and then I flew her to Vegas
to get married.
- Like for real you got married?
- A hundred percent real.
I was nervous because at first you have to go
to like this courthouse to get the papers
(all laughing)
and I was like, "Maybe I shouldn't do this cause
this is like pretty serious"--
(all laughing)
but then I also like I also didn't wanna fake it.
So, getting married is so easy, so easy.
(all laughs)
- It took like--
- Staying married is a little more difficult.
- Bingo, that's what I found out too.
So yes we got married and then we flew to Hawaii
for our honeymoon.
And we did this in three, four days without him
knowing where I was.
So we went to the honeymoon, she stayed down on the ground
while I was sky diving.
- You married his mom?
First of all, she's funny.
- She's great.
- I love his mom.
- She's so great.
At first she was like, she was confused but then I
was like, "I wanna be Jason's stepdad".
(all laughing)
- And she was like all for it, yeah.
(audience applauding)
- That is hilarious.
- Thanks.
And then four days later we flew back and we went
back into the car we were before and I showed him
the documents, all the courthouse documents that I'm
officially his new stepdad and that was one
of my favorite moments.
- Oh my--
- He loved it too.
He was glad his mom was in town cause I brought her
from Hawaii to L.A. so everyone won at the end.
- Oh my gosh, that's amazing.
Can we roll a part of that?
Can we see part of that cause I wanna see it.
- Me too.
- Will you marry me?
- Are you outta your mind?
- I wanna be Jason's stepdad.
- Oh, that would be hysterical.
- That's why I'm here.
(both laughing)
- By the power vested in me by the state of Nevada
I now pronounce you husband and wife.
You may kiss the bride.
- I love you.
- Okay, let's go.
(audience applauding)
- [David] Very cute.
- [Octavia] Their mom was amazing.
- Yeah that was fun.
- That's like the best prank ever.
- Yeah, that's a lot of fun to do.
- Wow.
- I would recommend everybody marries
their best friend's mom.
He took it very well, that's the best part is he
was such a good sport about it.
- That's so awesome, um so no but I did hear
that you have a Nickelodeon show right?
- I do yeah.
- Yeah, what's it about?
- Okay so it's America's Most Musical Family.
Yeah, it's a music competition show, it's the best.
- [Kelly] And they're all families?
- [David] All families, everybody's related in some
type of way.
There's 30 of em, they're already all extremely,
extremely talented families so everybody just
has like killer talent.
And we're kinda close to the finals now, so we're
nearing down to the final person.
Winner gets $250,000 and a recording contract.
- Wow.
(audience applauding)
- It's really cool.
Every family, it's insane how talented they are.
- That's cool, what a great concept.
- It is, yeah, I'm surprised no one's done it yet.
- Yeah, me too honestly, yeah.
All right, I'm gonna watch that, all right.